hi there i'm going to show you some of
my favorite japanese recipes to make
during summer time
june is japan's rainy season it's not a
pleasant time
but the rain brings out japan's natural
beauty
especially in plants like trees and
flowers
one particularly loved flower in japan
is the hyderanja
and they are beautiful during this
season
a hydrangeas color depends on the ph
level of soil
so if the soil is acidic pet outstand
blue
if the soil is neutral or basic they
tend to have pink or
red color we used red cabbage as natural
food dye
red cabbage also acts similarly to
hydrangeas
when you simmer with water the water
turns purple
but if you add lemon it turns pink
i made a color changing cocktail video
before using the same trick
some people were worried that it would
taste like cabbage
but we are using such a small amount
that it won't affect the flavor
the tasty japan team made a traditional
japanese confectionary
or as we call them wagashi wagashi
designs reflect the seasons
so this hydrangea design is perfect for
the early summer
wagashi is usually solved with tea
it pairs well with bitter matcha if you
join the tea ceremony
you will recognize wagashi's designs
differ from season to
season the purpose of the tea ceremony
is not only to enjoy tea and wagashi
but also enjoy the changes of season
on july 7th japan celebrates tanabata
a star festival and it's based on an
old folktale these folk tales main
characters are two lovers
orihime the princess who lived the
clouds
and hikoboshi a celestial cowherd
according to the folk tale they are
separated by the milky way
and they can only meet once in a year
which is july 7th
at this festival we write down a wish on
rectangular paper
and tie it with a string to a bamboo
tree
the folktale and celebration originated
as a chinese folk tale
they also celebrate july 7th in china
but according to my chinese co-worker
jin
they celebrate a little bit differently
nowadays
it's more like valentine's day in china
so
couples exchange gifts on july 7th
i've also heard that it's celebrated
across asia
so leave a note in the comments about
how you celebrate
in japan traditionally we so many
noodles to celebrate tanabata
but milky way-inspired or star-shaped
foods are very popular way to celebrate
this day
for this video the tasty japan team made
no-bake
cheesecake with blue agar jelly they
also used
silver sprinkles so it looks like stars
floating in the milky way
my co-worker alby made this video when
we went to japan a couple years ago
tonkatsu or fried pork is a popular
topping for curry
we eat curry all year round but for me
japanese curry reminds me of
summer in japan i think it's because we
go camping every summer
and we make curry during our camping
trip
curry is a staple camping food in japan
as well as a quick
and easy meal to cook when you don't
have a lot of time
curry's main ingredients are onion
potato carrot and meat
curry root cubes are sold at any grocery
store in japan
we normally use these blocks so don't
worry
you aren't missing out by not making it
from scratch
you can easily find it at the asian
grocery store in the states
the taste is sweeter and not too spicy
than
indian curry it's a different experience
so definitely try it for an easy weekday
meal
here chichuka is chilled noodles usually
topped with a thinly sliced egg omelet
cucumber ham and tomato
it's a summer staple noodle dish and can
only be found
during the summer you know that sama is
around the corner
when ramen shops begin to hang banners
and posters
to let customers know that here strugga
is finally available
when the weather is too hot you'll tend
to lose your appetite
but here's chuka is a perfect dish for
that
it's light and cold and this sweet tangy
sauce will stimulate your appetite
the most popular style is soy sauce and
vinegar based sauce
but there is another popular style with
a sesame based
sauce it's creamier than the soy
sauce-based
sauce but both are very popular samadhi
sheets
sama in japan is very humid but there
are lots of food that you can only find
during summer like this hiyashiyuka
it gets really hot during summer time in
japan and here in l.a
but wherever you are i hope you will try
these recipes
and have a delicious and refreshing
summer
oh yes
[Music]
you